that boys fan Boys the boys who carried
the fan fan boys fan Boys the boys who
had a plan for the way was long and the
day was hot the boys were always
prepared neither sand nor heat would
assail their feet they did what no
others had dared that boys
the boys who carried the fan and boys
and boys the boys who had a plan the
Fanboys were on no train to Laredo when
Bandits made an assault but but the
Fanboys fan made a win so mighty of a
banditry came to a halt and boys and
boys the boys who carried the fan fan
boys Fanboys the boys who had a plan the
magistrate said we're all very grateful
but it's time for an end to your fun he
said to the boys it's your fan or your
freedom and you may only have one and
boys and boys the boys who carried the
fan fan boys and boys the boys who had a
plan the boy saw the land was crying for
justice yet they knew that this wasn't
the way
so they put down their fan and they
picked up their notebooks and this is
what they had to say
though we lay down our fan this day you
too can have the power to unite phrases
words and clauses with a coordinating
conjunctions of English
which are
four
and more
but
or yet
so
you too can harness the power of the
Fanboys
the boys
remember the boys with a fan